the road to corruption is paved with
good intentions
or so it would seem after this week's
revelation that
after years of claiming they're getting
their houses in order
renowned banks continue to aid and abet
illegal money laundering
an international consortium of
investigative journalists
is behind the massive leak of documents
from the u.s financial crimes
enforcement
network or fincen for short documents
that are studded with
prominent names from united states
president donald trump
on one side of the atlantic to germany's
deutsche bank on the other it seems to
have complied with rules to report
suspicious transactions
but took few steps to rein them in
our topic money laundering oligarchs
terrorists
how corrupt are the banks
[Music]
welcome to to the point it's a pleasure
to introduce our guests
daniel drepper is editor-in-chief of
buzzfeed
news germany and he says the suspicious
activity reports give banks a free pass
to keep moving dirty money
and collect the fees and it's a pleasure
to welcome matthew karnichig to the
program
he's chief europe correspondent for
politico
and he believes these scandals are just
the latest indication that germany's
banking sector is neither financially
nor
culturally sound and great to have with
us as well vendelina fundraido she works
for the british economist
and she thinks justice deutsche bank was
finally starting to recover the
revelations related to its involvement
in money laundering in the fincen files
are a huge setback
so let me begin by asking about the back
story on these revelations buzzfeed news
in fact
was one of the media institutions that
was
involved in uh in proofreading and
essentially researching
the documents so can you give us a short
version of exactly what's going on here
sure buzzfeed news in the u.s our u.s
investigative team
shared these files with the icaj the
international consortium of
investigative journalists and they
got in all these different media
organizations from all over the world
like they did with panama papers
paradise papers all these other
big leaks over the last few years and
then about 400 people
went to work and reached researched them
cleaned them
looked into them and yeah got stories
ready for about a year and so we
published last sunday
and the original source of the documents
a whistleblower
yeah so buzzfeed doesn't comment on that
i'm sorry
okay matthew karnichig
in the era of alternative facts
as they are sometimes called can we be
sure that these
revelations are truly accurate and that
the
implications are as grave as they seem
well to be honest i don't think we can
be sure until it goes to the courts
until
prosecutors look at it and uh you know
file indictments and so forth
and you know this is one of one of the
problems
of this environment that we're in there
there are all kinds of data leaks
like this we've seen them over the years
and journalistically it's it's very
exciting but we often
don't really know even the people who
are reporting it what the motivations of
are the people who are leaking it who's
really you know behind this kind of
thing but they they have brought
to light a lot of maligned behavior it
it has to be said and this looks like
another such case
bendalina fondredo many viewers i think
will be inclined to say this hardly
comes as a surprise look at the
billionaire towers
in new york look at the mansions in
london
we always thought they're being financed
by ill-gotten
gains why should they care about
yet another revelation that the rich
don't play by the same rules as the rest
of us
it doesn't come as a huge surprise
you're right but first of all
it's the extent that these sums involved
you know two trillion dollars that's
that's
you know i think most of us can't even
imagine how much how much money that is
and then i think we all have to be aware
this is not something completely
abstract this is money that does
not is not used to build kindergartens
or
roads or schools i mean ordinary people
suffer
because this type of money laundering is
happening
so it's not something that only concerns
oligarchs or
drug dealers it concerns all of us
daniel drepper the institutions that
we are seeing implicated here are some
pretty illustrious names
j.p morgan hsbc deutsche bank just to
name
a few why them is there something
particular about
these banks or are they simply the tip
of a much bigger iceberg
so there are lots of banks in there like
these are obviously the biggest ones i
think
why they are so big and probably
everyone like um is looking into them is
first they move the most money
second they are the big bang banks that
have the access to the us dollar to the
financial market in the us and lots of
people who loan their money or have like
money they want to like
invest inject into the real economy want
to do that in
in the dollar market in the u.s so they
they use like smaller banks like afghan
united or tamiya bank and almaty or
some cyprus bank and then try to find a
relationship with the big bank and then
move the money to germany to the u.s and
so on
and matthew what kind of clients are we
talking about
here who is it who's laundering their
money with these banks
well it seems that most of the people
would be people we've never heard of
they're not
generally in the public view some of
them are but these are the people really
in the background who are often pulling
the strings who have their
hands in in various pots and know how to
work the system
especially in a lot of these you know
energy
rich countries and and places like that
and
they need to find a way to move their
ill-gotten gains out of
the countries where they're operating
and this network
of banks as daniel says provides them
you know a ready
opportunity to do so
i want to just bring in a short report
that we have
and uh i think one question many of us
perhaps
never actually pose but have you ever
thought about why is it called
money laundering the fact is the term
dates back to the u.s gangster al capone
to legalize his illicitly acquired gains
he purchased a bunch of laundromats
now today's criminals oligarchs and
terror
groups are working at a distinctly
larger scale
laundering doesn't only happen to
clothes but to money as well
it is estimated that between 800 billion
and 2 trillion u.s dollars are laundered
around the globe each year
current research reveals how the system
works using so-called
mirror trades billions of dollars from
illegal income
such as drug trafficking and
prostitution are pushed back
and forth between different banks and
thus failed
this money is then put into legal
investments
real estate is especially popular
because it can be paid for in cash in
many countries
such as the u.s the purified proceeds
then flow
into shell corporations in tax havens
such as the cayman islands
the international fight against money
laundering is often inadequate
because national money laundering
authorities are not as well networked as
the criminals
why is it so difficult for lawmakers to
put an end
to money laundering
vandalia let me pass that question
straight
on to you and i mentioned in fact
policymakers good intentions at the
outset set
of the show after revelations like the
panama papers the luanda
leaks and so on there's been a lot of
talk and also some action
on cracking down yet policy makers don't
seem to get the problem under control
why
they don't and the problem is that for a
bank there's a conflict of interest
because
in a bank needs to maximize with profits
a bank needs to make money
um these this type of business is very
lucrative
um it's often quite hard to detect
because obviously the money launders
will go to great lengths to
to obfuscate their money laundering so
there is
a great temptation not to look totally
too closely and to accept clients
banks should not have accepted and
should have known in the first place not
to accept because
maybe nobody will notice so daniel
dropper
banks are required to file these
suspicious activity reports that you
mentioned in your
opening statement you say that they
amount to a free pass for the banks to
keep on making money by laundering uh
dirty money but isn't this filing of
these reports a
first step toward compliance yeah i
think it's important that these
reports get filed the problem is i think
twofold one is
banks are interested in making money
they must make money because
obviously shareholders want to have some
some return on the invest
investment and so it's really every time
they see something weird in their
accounts
they see some shady money they have to
decide do we want to like make less
money and
drop the client or should we just file a
report
and then let's see if the authorities do
something with it and we just continue
our relationship with the client
and this is what like happens all the
time in the fincen files that like
a bank files a report it's from like for
a normal person looking at this it
seems really clear that this should not
be money being moved through deutsche
bank or commerce bank or
whatever but they continue their
relationship and then they say
yeah we did this report and as long as
the authorities don't do anything
we are fine with like working with these
clients and i think yeah that's a
problem because the authorities and we
might speak
about this later as well are definitely
not well equipped enough to like
hunt these illicit money flows like fast
enough let's come back to that in just a
moment but matthew let me bring you in
also in response to what we just heard
from fendalina because your opening
statement
said that this is a problem of a
defective corporate
culture at places like deutsche bank
but aren't we in a way putting banks in
a contradictory position their business
model is as vendelina said to make money
and yet we're also in a sense expecting
them to be self-enforcers
well i think we made it too easy for
them to be honest i mean the fact that
all they have to do is to check the box
and say well we
filed this report you know that's that's
the end of the story we don't have to
worry about it anymore
i think gives them an alibi where the
onus should really be
on them to do more to determine whether
these transactions
are sound or not um and
you know the fact is is that the the
regulators
uh should be much more involved here
than they have been and and they've
really dropped the ball the policy
makers by not making life more difficult
for the banks by not requiring them
to have stricter guidelines in terms of
reporting this activity
and the regulators for not acting on it
more effectively
so vendelina i asked you before why
normal citizens should care policymakers
you would think would have very good
reason to care
and to do a lot more because just one
fascinating statistic i
recently encountered the amount of money
that has left africa
through illicit financial transactions
meaning corruption
uh parking money in tax havens and so on
more than equals what africa has
received in development aid
over the past 50 years so it seems like
governments both donor governments and
also african governments themselves
would have ample
incentive to crack down more effectively
absolutely i mean the figure you cite is
heartbreaking if you think about it you
know what what good could have been done
with the money that left the country
um absolutely and policy makers do have
the right incentives and should
should do more but these things happen
so slowly i mean if you look at germany
now the card scanner surely must have
shown that
buffing is not really very good at its
job should have done a better job
in being the german financial supervisor
supervisory authority a german regulator
and if not
wirecart then this latest revelation
should be a reason to
give baffin more teeth to reform the way
they do
they do their work to maybe employ more
people to to
to to police these things would it
happen yes hopefully yes but
as you know these things even with the
best of intentions move
far too slowly for a problem of such a
scope
i do want to come back to the german
picture in a moment
but uh let's perhaps stay with the
international one
first of all and daniel dropper the
customers
on these mirror trades that were
mentioned in our report
they include terrorist groups they
include
drug cartels the united states
government
spends billions fighting those
two entities drug cartels and
terrorist groups and yet the journalists
consortium behind the fincen leaps in
leaks including
buzzfeed said that the u.s is the
machine
rune room of money laundering so what's
behind that paradox
like i like we said before i think the
main thing is that it's
it's really um there's there has to be a
lot of effort
put into to finding out like how to stop
this like
like the defense and like the authority
that like this
these fights are named after they have
270 employees
but they get 2 million reports every
year i think
it's every year every month i don't know
but it's like it's millions of reports
every year and they have 270 people to
check on them
like how are they able to go go after
every everything and
and everyone so i think that's like the
main thing is
it's a huge system there are like
billions ever like i think it's five
billions of money
every day laundered all over the world
um
it's very complicated these people go to
to do two great lengths
to hide their their methods and then we
have like you have like
like a couple of dozen people hunting
them down and that's like definitely not
going to work
i think another issue just on that
quickly is that if something is
happening
outside of the united states the united
states government is going to be less
interested in it
it doesn't mean that it's not going to
be interested
in the illegal activity but if people
are laundering money
in you know congo that's not going to be
high
on the united states government's list
and i think that
they also have this problem that they
have a very large financial services
sector which is a very lucrative
business in the united states the
biggest banks in the world are all
american banks and they make a lot of
money by shifting money around the world
i think
you know it has to be said there are
plenty of legitimate reasons to be
transferring
money in these sums uh around the world
for companies and governments and so
forth so it's very difficult to keep
track of it all but i don't think that
they have a real
you know baked in incentive to go after
what's you know happening in the third
world so let's talk about
uh europe's incentive uh because in fact
the european commission has had quite a
bit to say
on uh money laundering in the last few
years claims to want to do a great deal
more
to crack down and yet the world's tax
havens include
some leading european centers like the
netherlands switzerland ireland
luxembourg play a huge role in the
machinery of the
money laundering system so clearly this
is an area where we need
a true european approach also a global
approach
but how likely are we to get that at a
time
where in essence we're seeing
deglobalization
and a retreat from multilateralism
well in europe it's also worth
remembering that john claude juncker who
was president of the european commission
was also the finance minister and prime
minister of luxembourg for
uh 20 years and oversaw many of these
activities
up until 2014 when he became the
president of the european commission and
that didn't
halt his rise i think that there have
been some
reforms in europe there are tougher
controls on a lot of the
tax havens for example but the
the core issue here is that the people
who are doing this are always one step
ahead
they will always find a new way to
undermine the system or at least that's
been the history of it
and the people who are policing it are
often civil servants
who do not have the resources they often
don't have the ambition
to go after these things and it's only
until these types of stories
come to light that people take a second
look at it and say well we need to get
that under control and unfortunately the
pattern has been
you get this problem under control and
then they find another way to do exactly
the same thing
so i think this this is the the dynamic
that needs to
you know change eventually in germany
currently
holds the rotating presidency of the
financial action
task force which is in fact one of the
leading multilateral institutions
trying to get this problem under control
but some critics say that germany itself
is too lacks
when it comes to illicit transactions is
that right
uh yes i think unfortunately there's the
latest
findings of buzzfeed and others have
proven that germany is two lakhs i mean
deutsche bank um
plays a very prominent role in in money
laundering according to these
um i think of the two trillion dollars
about
one about half where somehow had gone
through deutsche bank at some point
i mean so it was one of the biggest
players in this
and it's it's germany's biggest bank
germany's old one of germany's oldest
and biggest banks so
um surely that shows that germany has
been two lakhs
let us dive deeper on the role of a bank
that
in fact once was the titan of germany's
financial
sector deutsche bank has been
the topic of prior reports of
dubious dealings
from the flagship of german business to
a scandal group
deutsche bank rather than success
stories
dark businesses keep coming to light one
of the biggest scandals
deutsche bank's role in the 2007
financial crisis
the u.s judiciary handed the company a
fine of more than 7 billion
for dubious mortgage transactions it
accused the bank of having contributed
to the real estate crisis
in 2013 the eu commission imposed a fine
of 1.7 billion euros on six major banks
for manipulating important reference
interest rates
such as euroboard and libor deutsche
bank was one of them
the russia affair came to light in 2015.
deutsche bank customers are said to have
laundered around 10 billion dollars of
illegal earnings in russian rubles
through the financial centers of moscow
new york and london
president donald trump has also been a
special client of deutsche bank for more
than 20 years
with his real estate financed by the
bank he also did business with
kremlin-associated russian oligarchs
how corrupt is deutsche bank
vandalina i'll pass that question
straight on to you clearly deutsche
bank's business model has
involved a lot of smoke and mirrors your
opening statement said
the bank was just beginning to recover
really
it did at the for a short time at the
beginning of the year the
share price did actually rise which
hasn't happened in a long time and it
seemed that
finally deutsche bank was stabilizing
but then of course
two things happened one was the kobet
crisis which
which which hits the the bank quite
badly and now
now this thing these these revelations
so it doesn't really
look as if deutsche bank were
stabilizing anytime soon so
matthew recover in share price is
one part of the issue but of course
recover is also a question of whether
they
can recover internally from what you
described
as a very problematic corporate culture
where is that coming from
well it just it comes from the history
of the bank quite frankly i mean this is
nothing new there have been you know
books written about the corruption
at deutsche bank and and it continues
you know a few a few years ago i
reported on a story where you had the
senior people in the bank ordering uh
the spying on
a uh on a shareholder who was there was
a gadfly shareholder who was making
trouble
and they hired a security firm to go
and spy on him uh at his vacation home
in in spain and they even rented the
house i mean these are extraordinary
measures that they've gone to
over the years and there's just one
thing after another if you look at any
major
financial scandal in germany over the
past 50 years you can
bet that deutsche bank will be right in
the middle of it do you see signs of
recovery in word
well i think you know if you could talk
about the share prices one thing 10
years ago the share price was at about
50 euros it's now at about
six euros i think that there are serious
concerns about the health of the bank
uh still um you know it's still losing
money
so you know i i think that uh
it is it is a problem for the german
government when when i was uh covering
wall street uh a decade ago
during the financial crisis the other
banks in the u.s were always pointing to
deutsche bank and saying if it weren't
for the german government standing
behind deutsche bank they would
definitely need
a bailout and i i think you know this is
always sort of the unsaid thing is that
everybody knows
that uh the german government will back
deutsche bank up at the end of the day
because it's just too big to fail it is
literally
too big to fail so daniel drapper one
long-term customer of deutsche bank
mentioned in the fin sen leaks is
donald trump and buzzfeed news research
identifies around 1300 dubious real
estate transactions
involving apartments in trump-owned
buildings
so does that make the president of the
united states complicit
in these transactions is he in violation
of anti-money laundering laws
i don't know if i can like absolutely um
evaluate that um but um you can
definitely see
in these files but also as and as you
said like before
long before that um lots of his business
transactions are connected to
gangsters two money launderers two
mobsters too people from
um eastern europe and um eurasia um
definitely trying to inject their money
into the u.s market
um you have some examples in the files
but like people
who who definitely didn't get their
money from like honest work and buy
apartments and trump towers and you have
like a story from buzzfeed from last
year
um that like laid out in detail how he
tried to like
finance a trump tower in moscow and gift
the biggest apartment to putin
um so there are like lots of lots of
things that he's
doing with the help of deutsche bank
that are definitely not not
really clean matthew investigative
journalists and also
some lawyers have long contended that
the smoking gun
in trump's relations with russia is in
fact
financial do the fincen leaks offer any
proof of that
well they certainly offer some
indication that there is more than
meets the eye and i think this is the
reason that trump
has been uh so forceful in trying to
prevent investigators in the united
states from getting either
his uh tax returns or his financial
records related to deutsche bank and it
has to be said it's not just that
deutsche bank did business with donald
trump they were the only bank who was
willing to lend him money when all the
other
major lenders in the united states said
you know there's no way we're giving
this guy any more money
so they have i think also a lot to
answer for here so it's not in their
interest
either to really provide this
information
and you know the courts are um
you know dealing with with this issue as
as we speak so
you know it's not likely to happen
before the election but i think someday
we'll know more
about both donald trump's finances and
the role that deutsche bank has played
let me ask all of you because we're
nearly at the end of our time
vendelina you described the fact that
the banks in some senses are overwhelmed
by the sheer volume and complexity
of these things artificial intelligence
could it
pose a possible solution i think it
could be part of a solution i'm not
enough of an expert on
you know explaining exactly how that
could work but
because it is so complex it involves i
think there's so many little pieces of a
puzzle i can well imagine ai playing a
big role
thank you one word answer is anything
really going to change daniel dripper
if the regulators get more power maybe
in the long term now
thank you very much to all of you for
being with us thanks to all of you for
tuning in
see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you